[Music]
well this sucked plains the spin-off
film in the apparent cinematic universe
created from Pixar's Cars either that or
it's a cinematic universe around planes
trains and automobiles just missing the
trains part or knows I drop as many
f-bombs while watching it if you see my
past reviews you know I'm not the
biggest fan of the cars movies but God
after seeing this one I may have to
rethink it because Christ Christ it is
the most obvious commercial generic
bland piece of crap that Disney could
put out the story forget it I can just
tell you the first sentence and you can
predict everything that's going to
happen let's try it a crop duster named
dusty wants to enter a race there don't
you know everything that's gonna happen
after I say that he's gonna be a scrub
he's gonna be an underdog but he finds
this old wise mentor who's gonna teach
him the ways but he has a tragic past
but we don't get to that yet we're gonna
get to that later in some sort of big
reveal we find out that dusty has a
fault that should make him incapable of
racing in this case he's afraid of
heights I know that's already confusing
because he's a goddamn plane
he's already high off the ground but
this is like really a high off the
ground yeah it's so stupid but he enters
the race with a whole bunch of colorful
characters and of course there's a
big-shot bully who's always the winner
but as the underdog starts to climb up
he sabotages him cheating and of course
at the end it's really close an Adam
Sandler sports movie would have more
originality than this I guess you could
say I expect more out of Pixar but it's
not even a Pixar movie yeah their name
isn't on it John Lasseter produced it
and helped with the story but it's
technically just a Disney product
despite it clearly taking place in the
Cars universe but okay there's been more
cliche generic stories out there that
have been turned into something really
cool I have no idea why I mention that
because this clearly isn't one of those
movies I guess some of the bare
essentials are there like the acting's
okay it's bright it's colorful but these
characters in almost in no way seem
alive by god I hate referencing
something good about cars but when you
see them moving when you see them
talking when you see them going through
a motion
it looks like they're going through
these emotions the kind of shrug and
shift and if they're sad they'll kind of
move said if they're happy they'll kind
of move happy here
they just look like toys dead lifeless
toys that somehow eight celebrities and
their voices are coming out of them
we're in cars they move like characters
here they move like planes you're just
looking at planes flying around circling
around moving even the distance between
the eyes and the mouth creates a
separation they're just so far apart
from each other that it's hard to be
like yeah I'm getting legit emotion out
of these characters and you could be
like well who cares it's just a kid's
film you're not supposed to get much
emotion but get this one of the
characters has a backstory that has a
lot of death in it yeah like he leads an
entire squad to their deaths they're
burning alive and exploding and going
into the water and as dramatic music is
playing planes got the employees yeah
planes is gonna make you cry I guess
look at this are these the kind of
designs you would expect to get like
emotion out of no clearly not even cars
three with that ridiculously serious
trailer didn't go this serious what the
hell were these filmmakers thinking but
alright maybe we can overlook that if
there's a lot of comedy in this I mean
there's a lot of comedic potential with
planes and a plane universe but we got
here
oh look throne the USS power
I'm saying that's right I just had to
let that sink it flies in Howard get the
word flies in it and their planes Disney
you know what makes it even creepier the
flies in Hauer is apparently alive to
look it has eyes there's probably a
mouth underwater that can't talk you
just get bubbles and and the second
I just want to flip all those stupid
cars and planes over and be like I'm a
man I'm a human being
this world this is insane
yeah I guess on top of everything else
it's just kind of creepy looking at
these things like when one stalls it
just goes into the water I'm like how do
they swim I guess they don't cuz you
can't really move the wings they're just
kind of these dead planes that have eyes
on them so oh it's just disturbing
watching them I don't like it it's
unpleasant just no no the amount of
laziness and the storytelling and design
is just amazing you can't believe this
came from Disney
now with Pixar I mean okay I guess Pixar
time ripped off from Disney and Disney
kind of ripped off from Pixar actually
it's kind of a weird back and forth way
of going but still this movie is awful
the tone doesn't work the jokes don't
work it's visually boring and it's a bad
idea that's a spin off of another bad
idea I guess if you have little kids
they can probably watch it okay though
again the kind of big mass water in the
middle might throw them off a bit it's
just a waste it's a waste of great
animators it's a waste of good
storytellers it's a waste of a good cast
it probably goes without saying but fly
the hell away from this one as quickly
as you can
you